speed multiplied by time is equal to
distance this tells us that if we know
any two parameters we can easily find
the third but that's not all it tells us
a lot more if one of the parameters is
constant then the other two are related
to each other in a special way let's
assume that the distance is constant if
D is constant and the speed is increased
by some factor the time will be
decreased by the same factor let's take
an example to understand this let's say
you travel from your home to the office
at 40 km/h and the distance to the
office is 40 kilometres so you would
take one hour to reach work on the way
back you travel at 20 km/h the distance
is not changing it will remain 40 as the
speed is 20 kilometres per hour the time
taken to reach back home will be 2 hours
what do you notice here the speed is
scaled down by a factor of 2 and the
time is scaled up by a factor of 2 if D
is constant and speed is multiplied by a
factor then time will be divided by that
same factor this is called inverse
variation something that we have learnt
in school and conveniently forgotten to
apply it in our daily routine what if
the speed is constant if speed is
constant and time is scaled up by a
factor then the distance will also be
scaled up by the same factor 20 times 3
is 60 and 20 times 6 is 120 when T is
multiplied by 2 D is also multiplied by
2 this is called direct variation and
similarly if T is constant and the speed
is increased by a factor then the
distance will also be increased by the
same factor this again is direct
variation both increasing or both
decreasing is direct and 1 increasing
and other decreasing is inverse
variation this is important
and you need to understand this well
let's take a few more examples
we know that speed multiplied by time is
equal to distance let's assume the
serried is constant 4 times 3 is equal
to 12 and 4 times 6 is equal to 24 the
speed is constant the time is scaled up
by a factor of 2 and the distance is
also scaled up by a factor of 2 so when
speed is constant and time is multiplied
by 2 the distance will also be
multiplied by 2 if distance is
multiplied by 4 then the time taken will
also be multiplied by 4 and what about
the case when the time is constant when
time is constant we can say that speed
and distance are directly proportional
when time taken is constant and speed is
multiplied by 2 the distance will also
be scaled up by 2 and if the distance is
multiplied by 3 the speed will also be
scaled up by a factor of 3 this is
direct variation again and what if the
distance traveled is constant if the
speed is multiplied by 2 then the time
taken will be multiplied by 1/2 or
divided by 2 if the time taken is
multiplied by 3 then the speed will be
multiplied by 1 over 3 this is in direct
variation take an example where distance
is constant 3 times 4 is equal to 12 and
6 times 2 is equal to 12 the distance is
constant the speed is multiplied by 2
and the time taken is multiplied by 1/2
these simple concepts help us in solving
time speed distance problems really
quickly especially when one parameter is
constant so make sure you understand
them really well
you